well despite president-elect joe biden
taking nevada ballots are still being
counted
and today clark county held yet another
update while addressing some fraud
concerns brought up by the trump
administration
joe mohler is live just outside of the
election headquarters tonight in north
las vegas with an update
joe
nearly a week after election day votes
continue to be counted here at the
election center and during that daily
update today
the registrar of voters did take some
time to address fraud
they seem to have a pep in their step
because they know that we're getting
close to the end here
clark county registrar of voters joe
gloria says while ballot county
continues the end is near
bulk of the ballots mail ballots are in
the system now
there are a few thousand that need
signature validation and sixty thousand
provisional ballots that need to be
reviewed and counted
as for accusations regarding fraud
gloria says they will investigate any
cases
any serious allegations brought to this
office is always taken seriously and we
forward the information because we have
it
monday president trump took aim at
nevada tweeting there is a cesspool of
voter fraud
this includes allegations that at least
two votes were cast on behalf of dead
people in clark county
over the weekend protests continued and
monday the trump administration
addressed it
we now have thousands of examples of
voter irregularity gloria said any
allegation of fraud is sent to the
secretary of state's office
they have an investigative team they are
currently looking into quite a few
things
for those folks in the general public we
have the data so if there's anything
that's been done
illegally unfortunately we're gonna
we're gonna find it gloria says he has
confidence in the elections process
in clark county and so should the public
the secretary i'm certain
is going to be vigorously going after
anybody who tried to test the system so
yes they should have confidence in our
voting system
[Music]
now back out here live mail balance will
be continued to be received until
tomorrow and the update this morning he
said
since the last update there was about
two dozen mail ballots that
came in they will continue to count
until thursday and he says they plan
to be finished by then reporting live in
north las vegas joe moore 8 news now